welcome to this video playing easel call
yeah this is so cool and as his name
right Leon it's so cool nem I had a
terrible score against tampa three wins
six losses it's not good but I have no
particular memory about those games no I
don't know so we get a double fianchetto
Kings Indian double fianchetto okay so
he's playing that law in him taking with
a coupon okay I think I'm taking it go
here for long castles hmm I have no idea
what I did against that guy well that's
debatable can always take now on c6
sometimes a very good option but I'm
keeping i'm waiting waiting with that a
bit ok now i can take them and go f3 no
cam it's not it's not super convincing
you can go to e6 of course mm-hmm ok ok
maybe that one
that probably I should have taken and go
every the show page six okay it's a pin
that I cannot go h3 cannot go III am but
I can gotcha do this right has to go
back and then here and I don't really
know what this has accomplished okay I'm
94 as an idea now for possible night c5a
Knight f6 wow that's a weird move
okay did not expect dead at all
Jeff so I've night c5 going for me okay
Wow
so okay so i can I cannot take I cannot
take because rugby eight trap that night
yeah I am going for some tricks iam
anyway I just got to should be six some
jump we should be fair the fun resource
hmm yeah I really should have gotten
more out of that I mean it was it was
just a terrible position for black so
this is not really really that brilliant
c4 c5 maybe so here 95 is not leading
anywhere can I as before ok I have to be
a bit quicker here takes Knight e5 looks
looks interesting I didn't really
calculate it that much
b5 is an idea though I mean I don't know
yeah I'm probably had he said probably
it was good for him to to take it I can
take this c5 porn
Jackie now it's got 93 m that's it's a
problem root leaf is not possible due to
do to that check
have to get out of those those Forks
yeah of course that wasn't wasn't really
well Pletcher by me instead of having a
clearly better position this is kind of
struggling and they were definitely
possibility is to get a clear advantage
I mean not no question there so still
it's not easy for him to play this
position okay I mean I have some
compensation for that porn that's what
I'm trying to say 93 I have worked in
one that's important
okay let's just attack this by okay I'm
not threatening to take h6 probably
because of rook do you want check g5
okay impossible now to calculate
everything so let's push that I can take
I can take on b2 and then Bishop before
check that is that is rather sad I di FF
k f king bee three takes King be three
at the end so that's not a problem
five really that's a time one who
readily relaxed smooth but now he can
today yeah I had an idea with that silly
move jack meaning it's not red wasn't
really silly ah protected that night I
what a shame what a shame yeah that's
probably how I I have this bad score
against the sky screwing up good
positions very likely the the point or
the the keys man I'm running it to 93 j
yeah we're just just going through the
motions him right resign okay so let's
check how this game could have been one
from here I'm have no doubt that why
this lot better so let's check him takes
checks and five hmm it's not that much
comp is just on 0.5 surprisingly I was
thinking that right TM there should be
more okay night c4 is actually better
him okay okay it's not that terrible I
mean it's amazing that it's not better
check yeah okay Bishop f8 is kind of
lucky and that this is there otherwise
you just resins this but it is it is
there them yeah I mean it'sit's this is
the kind of thing that nobody plans
before and it's just just there and then
I don't have any have a great great
continuation so I probably have to do
this for 95 this is the computer line
yeah it's nice but not winning so blacks
position wasn't as bad as I thought it
is it really looked totally
uncoordinated down but should be five is
a really strange move but ok nitey force
is actually the best one okay
threatening look d5 and just see form
yeah this is the this is the best one
according to the comp with this line now
okay that's very nice young the bishop
is a little bit more spaced out plus one
hmm ok ok so of course may i did not see
bishop fa this is the problem really I
was counting on on on 95 and well if he
has to go b6 something like that is a
disaster right but this is working and
here yeah it's not that is not that
great actually I mean I tried hard to to
push a little bit here before was
probably too dicey check check but a
factor position was I mean around here
this isn't their bad
I mean I don't I really believe that is
that this is that bad okay the engine
wants to go a three but anyway i'm
curious him like here if I I mean this
is what's very silly to I mean I totally
forgot that this before night is now is
now covered I after that what actually
is in good shape yeah i mean i have g600
a jade so hmm yeah that was a bad game
yeah and this andrew cage i'd made so he
has to check give up the exchange that's
that's very bad so that was that was
also a possibility to win yeah well okay
this is just a search and a big blunder
and unfortunately you have absolutely no
chance here with with white now he's got
this the pieces are very nicely
coordinated so you have no no real
possibility same okay well thanks for
watching